hi folks said here with AGS news update
for you over in Japan this morning
nintendo president satoru iwata
announced the company is working on a
new piece of gaming hardware codenamed
NX while specifics are limited it also
confirm the device would be something we
haven't seen from them before as proof
that Nintendo maintains strong
enthusiasm to the dedicated game system
business let me confirm that Nintendo is
currently developing a dedicated game
platform with a brand-new concept under
the development code name and X it's too
early to elaborate on the details of
this project but we hope to share more
information with you next year the press
conference which was translated live was
also held to announce in tendo's
partnership with Japanese mobile
specialists DN a together they're
planning to bring in Tendo properties to
your mobile devices the partnership will
play a major part in development of the
new system along with nintendo's new
membership service Nintendo's together
with DNA will jointly develop a new
membership service which encompasses the
existing Nintendo 3ds and Wii U's
systems the new hardware system with a
brand-new concept NX and smart devices
and PCs a Nintendo will be the primary
party to operate this new membership
service unlike the club nintendo
membership service that nintendo has
seen operating the new membership
service will include multiple devices
and creates a connection between
nintendo and each individual consumer
regardless of the device the consumer
uses this membership will form one of
the core elements of the new nintendo
platform that i just mentioned nintendo
have certainly been the most creative in
their Hardware thinking of the major
hardware developers so what kind of new
concepts we are likely to see in the NX
is entirely in the air given in tendo's
new dedication to gaming on mobile
devices it's quite likely we could be
looking at a new home console so what
are your hopes riding on mario kart on a
virtual reality device or zelda in 4k
also what are they likely to release it
as the Nintendo I are saw perhaps them
let me know all of your wildest
speculations in the comments below and
for all the latest on the Nintendo and
x stay tuned to gamespot com